for all of the books I don't have time
for I use short form which condenses
thousands of non-fiction books down into
an excellent summary that I can read or
listen to all at once short form goes
chapter by chapter providing deeper
analysis than other summary platforms
for a more comprehensive understanding
of any topic try it free and get 25 off
using my link below
welcome back everybody to the David
packman show Luke Beasley here filling
in for David while he is away you may
remember Ruby Freeman she was an
election worker in the state of Georgia
and became the center of conspiracy
theorists of course from the Maga right
to Trump himself spreading these
conspiracy theories Rudy Giuliani and uh
was accused of committing voter fraud in
her role as an election worker and of
course these claims were false but the
process kind of has to do what the
process has to do and so because these
claims were being made and being sent to
authorities constantly Non-Stop and
massive uh proportions the authorities
the Georgia state election board and
coordination with other entities did an
extensive investigation into a bunch of
different claims about the 2020 election
in the state of Georgia and just now
Ruby Freeman and her daughter are being
formally clear year previously election
officials were able to say there isn't
any evidence at this time of what is
being accused but they do have to go
through an investigation and of course
it did yield the exact results that we
would expect which is no these claims
were false after an extent investigation
and I used that wording because I'm
gonna let me resituate this court
because so many people will say and then
we'll dive into some of this and look at
a little bit of Ruby Freeman's testimony
on the January 6th committee
um previously so many people will say oh
the reason fraud hasn't been uncovered
is because
it hasn't been investigated properly oh
it's because they haven't done
investigations of depth extensive enough
to really uncover what's there it's
being hidden really effectively so you
have to do a really good investigation
but these claims get investigated
and
we know after those extensive
investigations that the claims are false
this is from NBC News years after their
lives were turned upside down by
conspiracy theorists Ruby Freeman and
her daughter wandrea Archie Moss were
officially cleared by Georgia
authorities on Tuesday and the impact on
their lives was devastating Georgia
state election board dismissed its
year-long investigation years long I
should say investigation into alleged
election fraud at the State Farm Arena
in Atlanta more than two years after
conspiracy theorists and then president
Donald Trump claimed that Freeman and
her daughter had committed election
fraud in the 2020 presidential election
the fraud claims were unsubstantiated
and found to have no merit the
investigation concluded
reporting on the work of the FBI the
Georgia Bureau of Investigations and
investigated from the Secretary of
State's office vetting the alleged fraud
and that goes through and we may more
from this article after taking a look
at this clip this is Ruby Freeman in
front of the January 6th select
committee testifying about her
experience having her life turned upside
down because of these lies
all because a group of people starting
with number 45
and his ally Rudy Giuliani decided to
scapegoat me and my daughter Shea
to push their own lives about how the
presidential election was stolen
there is nowhere I feel safe
nowhere
do you know how it feels to have
president of the United States to Target
you
the president of the United States is
supposed to represent every American
not to Target one
but he targeted me lady Ruby
a small business owner a mother a proud
American citizen who stand up
to help Fulton County run an election in
the middle of the pandemic
um
so a few things on this the first is
what I previously mentioned which is uh
that yes these things are investigated
yes they're taken seriously which is why
we shouldn't have so many bogus claims
being made because then it wastes a
whole lot of time and effort trying to
go through and make sure they get
properly and thoroughly debunked so
that's number one the claim of these
things don't get investigated is just
completely Ludacris number two is the
impact on people's lives of these lies
it matters it absolutely matters and
Ruby Freeman has had just a complete
devastating situation in her life that
was unnecessary because of these lies
just trying to serve her local election
process doing her civic duty uh going
above and beyond on that front and then
being targeted by the most powerful
person on the planet just because he
couldn't accept that he lost and that
brings us to the next point which is
that
once again we're reminded the danger of
someone like Trump or Trump himself ever
getting their hands on power again
because of the anti-democratic views of
this movement and anyone can be thrown
into
um the fire whatever the phrases can be
sacrificed their well-being can be
sacrificed in the eyes of these
anti-democratic leaders and
anti-democratic
supporters in the name of perpetuating
this narrative and so for her it was it
was false we're seeing now as we knew
before but once again after a years-long
investigation false false false but she
had to have her life turned upside down
because her life didn't matter as much
to the people making the claims as
believing that Trump still won and that
is what is so
um horrifying just to give you a little
bit more in case you're curious on this
story during their efforts to overturn
the results of the election Trump and
his Allied Giuliani repeatedly claimed
that freedom loss uh Freeman and Moss I
should say had committed election fraud
and they had this heavily edited clip to
try to make that point and this is just
super interesting to give you a sense of
how these conspiracy theories explode
Giuliani said Freeman and Moss were
passing USB drives like vials
um or heroin or of of heroin or cocaine
during ballot counting operations Moss
later explained her mother handed her a
ginger mint during ballot Counting
so you'll hear all of these stories of
USB drive for being handed and that was
an election fraud tactic somehow or
suitcases of ballots were being set on
the table and if you dive into each
individual one you understand oh wait
what they're saying either they're
seeing something incorrectly or they're
seeing something correctly but taking
that to an incorrect conclusion and this
is how conspiracy theories spin off this
is how people buy into these claims
despite there being no
evidence
well something I've been following
pretty closely on my show you can find
my show at Luke Beasley on YouTube is
the Bonkers uh hearings I know David's
been covering this too that Republicans
have been putting together in the House
of Representatives supposed to put
forward some argument in each of these
hearings and prove something and often
attack President Biden but so often the
word that I would say characterizes
these hearings from House Republicans is
backfire they keep
backfiring and today is yet another
example of this this is from earlier in
the week I didn't have a chance to cover
on my show or the Dave Hackman show so
I'm going to circle back to it
um now as we close the week and this had
to do with John Durham of course the
special counsel who investigated the
investigators in regard to the Russia uh
Pro Mueller investigation Crossfire
hurricane
and as was reported on by David by
myself it was a complete
while there are things in there that you
can find interesting and there are
notable parts of this Durham report
as a whole especially when you set it
next to what was promised from MaGa on
this Durham investigation it was a
nothing burger and it was supposed to
prove that there was this big conspiracy
at least in the eyes of Maga it was
supposed to prove that there's a
conspiracy to take down Trump by the FBI
and that's why the whole investigation
into Russian interference started in the
first place when in reality that's not
the case and that's not what Durham
uncovered and it mainly just uncovered
mistakes that were made in the
investigation fair enough make sure
those get corrected but clearly there
was good reason to investigate the
connection between the Trump campaign
and Russian government because of all
that we know is present there all the
connections that were uncovered but the
hearing most recently uh led by Jim
Jordan
didn't go too well where they brought
John Durham in front of the house
Judiciary Committee to
tout the success of this report I guess
and I'll show you a couple right Wingers
very angry about John Durham's
investigation and this hearing
specifically to give you a sense of how
this isn't going as they probably wanted
it to this is Steve Bannon first and
then we'll get into Democrats making
some great points right I mean yesterday
Jordan was pathetic he tried to make
Clark did he try to Saint Durham did he
try to make Durham Saint Durham
yeah absolutely I mean you know so
that's him saying Jim Jordan was
pathetic who was leading the hearing
that's not what you want to hear from a
right winger after one of these
political stunt hearings
um and then this is Matt Gates
questioning Durham and Matt Gates is
saying that Durham's investigation was a
failure but for the opposite reason
probably than you and I would think Matt
Gates thinks that Durham didn't uncover
what's there we realized he didn't
uncover what wasn't there
um but here's this Exchange
I think that's beyond the scope of
what's in the report it's literally the
scope of what your charging order is who
put it in motion we get after it was put
in motion the FBI did a bunch of wrong
and corrupt things totally understand
we're trying to deal with that but when
you are part of the cover-up Mr Durham
then it makes our job harder
yeah well if that's your thought I mean
there's no way of dissuading you from
that I can tell you that it's offensive
and that the people who worked on this
investigation have spent their lives
trying to protect people in this country
and pursue within the law
you tried two cases lost both of them
and then the One Plea guilty plea you
got Klein Smith Klein Smith is back to
practicing law in Washington DC today
that's beyond my control right but but
the the fact that you allowed that plea
to occur
right and and then the punishment was
insufficient the fact that you didn't
you didn't charge Andrew McCabe you
didn't convict the lion Democrats or the
lion Russians you didn't investigate
mifsud or the Mueller probe even though
as we sit here today in Black letter
that was your charge have you ever heard
of the Washington generals at the
Washington generals yes yeah and and
they're the team that basically gets
paid to show up and lose okay so again
Matt Gates is coming at a very different
perspective and I would say probably
rather dishonest one but he's
recognizing the failure of
um this Durham investigation because he
didn't really
uncover anything that wasn't already
covered by the inspector General's uh
investigation and the Mueller
investigation and I think any reasonable
person would say if you analyze the
facts of
both of those investigations and just
the whole situation kind of zoomed out
there was definitely reason to
investigate the connection and Russian
interference
and then we find that there isn't
evidence of trump directly coordinating
with the Russian government that's what
investigation are for and there's an
investigation of that or if there's not
proof of that uncovered in the
investigation then
um so be it and follow the facts and the
mistakes were made fair enough to
criticize but this idea that number one
there was nothing to be looked into by
the FBI and then by Mueller Lee in that
FBI investigation with all of the
convictions that Mueller got
and number two that this was a
conspiracy with the Democrats to take
down Trump
um rather
dishonest and then I have for you Adam
shift during this hearing
well your report
Mr Durham
doesn't dispute anything Mueller found
did it
no our object our aim was not to dispute
director Marlo I have the greatest
regard highest regard for director
Mueller he's a patriot the only
distinguishment between his
investigation and yours is he refused to
bring charges where he couldn't prove
guilty on a reasonable doubt and you did
and I've noted this in the past when
covering the Durham report but as you've
probably heard as well multiple times
Durham Pro two cases to trial and both
of them uh ended in acquittal and last
clip we'll look at just because both for
the sake of this hearing making sure the
attempt by the right to make the Durham
report something that it's not and also
just because it's representative of how
all of these political stunt hearings
aren't going well for uh the Republican
party I'll show you one more clip of Ted
Lou
now Mr Durham would like to ask you the
following simple yes or no questions
Trump's former campaign chairman Paul
manafort was convicted correct I'm sorry
could just repeat that Trump's former
campaign chairman Paul manafort was
convicted correct that's correct Trump's
reform policy advisor to the campaign
George Papadopoulos was convicted
correct it's correct Transformer Deputy
campaign manager Rick Gates was
convicted correct
none in connection with Russian trumps
all right
Mr Durham you can hold yourself out as
an objective Department of Justice
official or as a partisan hacked and the
more that you try to spend the facts and
not answer my questions you sound like
the latter so I'm just asked this simply
Trump's former National Security advisor
Michael Flynn was convicted correct
that's correct
Trump's longtime advisor Roger Stone was
convicted correct I'm sorry missed the
last time long time advisor Roger Stone
was convicted correct correct in
contrast to multiple Trump Associates
were convicted
you brought two cases your trial based
on this investigation and you lost both
and so I don't actually know what we're
doing here because the author of the
Durham report concedes that the FBI had
enough information to
investigate and thank goodness the FBI
did because multiple Trump Associates
who committed crimes were held
accountable
stop it there but
great points and
I really do wish
that the specifics of the claims could
be meaningfully broken down with a lot
of these people
um and imagine myself having a
one-on-one conversation with someone who
believes the FBI is being weaponized
against the conservatives and just go
one by one we went through yesterday and
likely we'll talk a little bit more
about it today the claim is being made
about Hunter Biden being treated with
kid clubs and if you walk through the
deal that he got it's very
uh expected very historically consistent
and uh same thing here where in any
extensive investigation can you find
problems and mistakes that were made a
hundred percent
but does that mean that it lives up to
the claim that was made about the
purpose of and the way the FBI went
about their investigation into the Trump
campaign the connection with Russia
Russian interference and all that no and
so a lot of the the layers as I
mentioned yesterday that are being laid
on to one another that build the
narrative in a lot of people's mind that
this is the reality the two-tier justice
system that targets conservatives helps
Democrats it's
um each layer if you discuss it
one-on-one it feels like a lot to them
but if you go one-on-one you realize
um it isn't what they think that it is
make sure you are uh subscribed to the
Dave Pacman show channel and my channel
on YouTube Luke Beasley
I often have a much longer list of
non-fiction books that I'd like to read
than I actually have the time for and
that's when summaries of books can be
really useful our sponsor short form is
the platform that goes Way Beyond what
other book summary platforms do because
short form provides a clear and concise
overview of the book that you can read
or listen to in one sitting but you also
get a ton of other crucial context about
how the book fits into the broader topic
like for example I went through the
short form guide for an American
sickness it's a book by Elizabeth
Rosenthal about the financial incentives
that plague the U.S health care System
many of which we've talked about short
form perfectly sums up the book's key
points but then it goes further it looks
at the background on how rosenthal's
perspective fits into the larger debate
on American Health Care and this just
gives you a more complete and balanced
understanding of the book and that's
what I love about short form short form
has every non-fiction genre imaginable
and they publish new book guides every
single week my audience can try short
form totally free and get 25 off a
subscription if you'd like at
shortform.com Pacman the link is down
below
well let's talk a little bit about
what's going on in the Republican
primary DeSantis got asked about uh the
hypothetical of if Trump ends up winning
the primary as right now he seems poised
to do would DeSantis endorse him support
him in the general election
um and as you can probably expect
DeSantis Dodge the question and start
talking about his handling of kovid and
Trump saying that New York handled it
better
um but we'll discuss this after taking a
look
regardless of sexual you I'm 100 uh
pledge to support Trump as a GOP nominee
so what I would say is this
um
when you are saying
that Cuomo did better on kovid than
Florida did
you are revealing yourself to just be
full of it nobody believes that and you
know why
[Applause]
and you know why I know that
because okay a couple of things then
we'll continue this is surface level
this is not super important but it
doesn't have an effect in politics
number one he always gets noticeably
nervous when he gets asked about Trump I
can kind of a little bit hear his breath
gets a little
um whatever you call that and also uh
people criticize him for this and I
didn't think about it that much until
now he really does have this really
whiny tone of voice but that's less
important continuing as I remember in
2020 and 2021 when he was praising
Florida for being open saying we did it
much better than New York and Michigan
and everyone was coming to Florida and
that we were one of the great governors
in the United States and he used to say
that all the time now all of a sudden
his tune is changing and I would just
tell people do you find it credible do
you honestly find it credible would you
have rather been in New York during
covid under Cuomo regime or would you
rather have been in the Free State of
Florida and I probably can count the
number of Republicans on my hand in the
nation who would have rather been under
Cuomo in New York and we know that and
so these are just uh frivolous
criticisms but uh in some respects I
think it shows that you know if you you
have to make that argument then you
probably don't have very good arguments
because the reality is everything he
said about us for years about how strong
we were how good we were how we've
delivered for the state those happen to
be true and now he's trying to backtrack
because he you know views he needs to do
that and he's saying things
okay so I know David has uh done deep
dives into kind of the way that the sand
just blows out of proportion how good
Florida has done and honestly a lot of
metrics but covid uh included and
Descendants the governance would be a
disaster Nationwide and all of that so
we'll set that aside but to the point of
oh Trump said all these good things
about me and now he's not can you
believe it yeah you lined up behind a
guy who understands nothing about actual
meaningful
um healthy loyalty and
um
cares only about someone as far as they
can further his own goals so that's very
unsurprising but the Santas did the same
thing right DeSantis was doing that
campaign ad so cringy saying uh I don't
know exactly the specifics of the ad but
um you'll remember he's sitting with a
book reading to his child and uh make
America great again and essentially
indoctrinating his child into being a
trump supporter showing the supporters
in Florida I guess that I would be a
good candidate because
I love Trump so much and I'm teaching my
child to be like Trump and now he
doesn't have that same
um tone when talking about Trump of
course that's what happens constantly in
politics especially with people that
don't actually care about the people
they purport to
um unless they're they're helping
themselves politically but as far as
polling right now will DeSantis have to
make the decision as far as supporting
Trump or not supporting Trump in the
general election probably he will based
on polling
right now uh 538 has Trump at a 52.5
percent
average uh percentage point average
there and then santus is down at 21.3
percent and then everyone else way lower
so especially in past primary times
could DeSantis make up that difference
could a candidate at 21 end up jumping
up and beating someone who is at 52 sure
but because of how well known and how
um set in the feelings about these two
candidates and Trump in particular this
particular primary is and the followers
of these different individuals
um really have a sense of especially who
Trump is the likelihood of a massive
shift is uh lesser it is not as likely
that will happen whereas other primaries
there's a lot of less known or a lot of
candidates that people aren't yet set in
their feelings about and so big shifts
really can happen especially this far
out from the actual election
um after debates and after lots of
campaigning and all of that but this is
a very different situation so likely
very soon distance will have to make a
decision about if he supports Trump in a
general and I can tell you almost 100
that he will support Trump if Trump's
the nominee against Biden that's just
how these things work unfortunately
we move from DeSantis to Trump himself
and more specifically his true social
activity Donald Trump posts these video
statements talking about different
things
um
often ranting about different subjects
this is kind of I guess his primary form
of campaigning because most of the time
he's just golfing and this one on true
social that we'll watch is titled
sometimes you have to put them in their
place and it's him lashing out at the
lower poll number uh candidates in the
GOP Primary field right now and I guess
answering the question
that he feels he's getting asked of why
are you attacking people who have really
low poll numbers ignore them and he's
saying this is why
um in
in traditional bunkers deranged Trump
fashion say don't punch down when
talking about people like Chris sununu
or sloppy Chris Christie or Ada
Hutchison I call him Ada not ASA because
of certain reasons
or others but sometimes it's necessary
to talk badly about those that for no
reason
other than politics speak badly about
you otherwise
the people that love you don't know
whether or not they're for real are they
saying the truth they're not so
sometimes you have to punch down and you
have to say what's happening otherwise
they won't understand it's not fair to
them
you have to put them
in proper perspective these bad people
you have to put them in their place
people like this are very destructive
and you have to tell the voters what
it's all about otherwise why should they
be able to understand it thank you very
much
so what he really means because I agree
that you have to tell voters why you're
better than other candidates but what he
really means in punching down is he has
to
scream that uh someone like Chris
Christie is really
dishonest and is sloppy Chris Christie
such a strange people forget that oh
apologies guys get this next video
queued out for you
um he has to say all that because as he
said otherwise people might think that
Chris Christie's statements about Trump
might be for real and this is Trump's
whole Playbook anyone who says something
slightly negative has to become an enemy
because then in the minds of his
followers it's really easy to think okay
I don't have to listen to the very
accurate criticisms coming from Chris
Christie because he's an enemy he's in
the enemy category he's sloppy Chris
Christie
such a strange nickname or Ada
Hutchinson or whoever
um and that's why he has to do that
because often they're saying very when
these Republicans finally turn on Trump
they'll say things that do need to be
heard by Trump's followers rare things
being said by people at least
um rare things to hear within the GOP
about Trump that are accurate his threat
to so many things our Democratic
institutions being such a prominent
example and finally someone in the
primary field like Chris Christie is
calling that out and others
um and then this was on Ron DeSantis
specifically
that Rhonda sanctimonious was a big
lockdown man here let me start this from
the beginning people forget that Rhonda
sanctimonious was a big lockdown man
early on as Governor he locked it down
and other Governors that were Republican
of nature did not lock down if you look
at South Carolina and Tennessee and
South Dakota and others they didn't lock
down but Florida was locked down he
locked it down okay we'll stop that one
there uh
it's interesting we talked about
yesterday the very
concerning
um
characteristic of this primary that's
getting developed where DeSantis and
Trump are going to try to argue over who
was the most irresponsible in their
handling of govit who rejected the
science the most who is against taking
precaution and did we take incorrect
ones here and there and did tons of
politicians make bad decisions and
hypocritical decisions and all of that
yes but does that mean we should have
gone radically in the direction that
maybe DeSantis Wishes the country had
gone uh no and now because the sentences
attack line against Trump is he was too
profound she and he was
pro-lockdown Trump has to turn around
and go no DeSantis was and they have to
argue about who took the science the
least seriously which is a really
strange
strange thing to be developing quickly
just to wrap up our discussion about
this primary
um the indictment interestingly the set
the second indictment the federal one is
having an effect on the Republican
primary not in a huge way but at least
in some way that is negative so this is
from CNN uh foreign president Donald
Trump support appears to have softened
following his indictment arrest on
federal charges according to a new CNN
poll
conducted by SSRS and we'll look at
first the whole country and then the GOP
specifically most Americans approve of
Trump's indictments stemming from his
alleged mishandling of classified
documents after leaving office even as
71 percent say politics played a role in
that charging decision though Trump
continues to lead the GOP field by a
wide margin in the race for the
Republican party's nomination for
president the poll suggests that his
support has declined as have positive
views of him among Republican and
Republican leading voters nearly a
quarter now say they would not consider
backing his candidacy under any
circumstances the survey also finds that
those GOP line voters not currently
backing his 2024 bid have different
views on his indictment and behavior
than those in his Corner that's pretty
obvious and then here's the notable
part overall 47 percent of Republicans
and republican-leaning registered voters
say Trump is their first choice in the
party's nomination for president down 53
percent in a May
CNN poll
um in additional Decline and support for
Trump's candidacy his favorability
rating among Republican line voters has
dipped from 77 in May to 67 percent now
so you're seeing shifts
um in the GOP and that could be in part
one of the most notable things that has
changed over the last few months is
Trump's legal troubles and so maybe the
idea of having
even possibly a convicted felon as your
candidate Isn't So appealing to some
Republicans even though many of them as
I very much witnessed at his arrest and
arraignment outside the Miami Federal
Courthouse a couple weeks ago many of
them still are very much on board one
lady said I would vote for him even if
he's in jail I don't care but some are
shifting and that's good to see
former president Barack Obama did an
interview recently on CNN and one of the
moments caught a lot of people's eyes
and it was pretty interesting I'll show
it to you it's on the subject of the
threat to democracy that is currently so
present especially because of the amaga
movement within the uh United States
right now
and within the Republican Party
specifically and uh Barack Obama
responded to that saying this
be creaky or not institutions in the
United States the spectacle of a former
president being federally indicted
how is the rest of the world the
Democratic World maybe even the
non-democratic world meant to interpret
that indictment and indeed the fact that
a federal indictee is running is able to
run for the highest office in the land
maybe even the world
it's less than ideal
but uh the fact that uh we have a former
president who is having to answer
to charges brought by prosecutors
does uphold the basis and you see the
lower third is talking about state of
democracy we'll get to that specific
topic Topic in a second quick notion
that nobody's above the law and the
allegations will now be sorted out
through a a court process and
I I I'm I think I'm more concerned when
it comes to the United States with the
fact that
not just one particular individual is
you know being accused of of uh
undermining existing laws but that more
broadly we've seen
whether it's through the gerrymandering
of districts whether it's uh you know
trying to silence critics uh through
changes in legislative process whether
it's
attempts to
intimidate the press
a strand of anti-democratic sentiment
that uh you know we've seen in in the
United States
it it's something that is right now most
prominent in the Republican party but I
don't think it's
um something that uh is unique to one
party I think there is a a less
tolerance for ideas that don't
um
suit us and it sort of the habits of a
free and open exchange of ideas and the
idea that
um
you know we all agree to the rules of
the game and even if the outcomes aren't
always the ones we like we still abide
by those rules I think that's weakened
uh
so the interesting part is that he
throws in and I think it's accurate but
within the context of how present it is
on the right right now
um throwing in that this isn't unique to
one party is definitely an interesting
sentiment
because I do think there's there's truth
to number one anyone can be susceptible
to prioritizing power and
um the ambition for a position of power
over
respect for
um Democratic institutions and the
Democratic process that and I think
recognizing that is important to make
sure that people don't fall into that to
make sure that people who support
democracy now stick to that even when we
really want to win I think that's really
important it's always important to make
sure we don't both sides sometimes right
Wingers will say well
people said that Hillary should have won
in 2016 that's the same thing as
um what's going on now or
people talked about Russian interference
that's the same thing as what's going on
now it's not even comparable there's a
big difference between
questioning in a general sense was this
fair if this had been different would
this person have won and saying our
election systems aren't working like our
election processes with the workers and
the
um casting of the ballot that is being
uh incorrectly run or their fraud
involved because then you're telling
people
that their voice doesn't matter and it's
being decided kind of on high or some
corrupt group of people or some
conspiracies deciding and that
definitely guts the legitimacy of
democracy and so I don't think ever
throwing into the same box the two
things is fair but I do think saying the
ambition for power especially in a time
where we're so divided and so Obama was
saying there
um we're getting less and less willing
to hear each other out
as Fighters for supporters of protecting
our democracy we have to commit to
making sure that never does the ambition
for power become more important than the
importance of protecting the
institutions and it is wild that we're
in a moment right now where this is what
we have to discuss for so long I think
we took for granted our uh Democratic
institutions we assumed with whatever is
going on our Democratic institutions
will continue to function but now both
with the election denying and the
attempts to keep Trump president and all
that has spun off of that but also once
again
contending with how anti-democratic
something like gerrymandering is and
that is done on both sides to different
extents it's quite the moment and
hopefully this Reckoning and the
negative parts of this moment will
motivate
uh will be a launch pad for a lot of us
to improve those systems and it is
something that I deal with on a smaller
level not denying elections or trying to
overthrow elections but gerrymandering
is a good example where do you stand on
do you gerrymander to get the correct
people into power so that they can
Implement laws to ban gerrymandering or
do you not play that game and get
crushed by Republicans and it's it's
tough and there's definitely a balancing
act there let me know what you think of
all this in the comments of this video
and make sure you are subscribed to my
YouTube channel at Luke Beasley on
YouTube
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
welcome back everybody to the show Luke
Beasley here filling in for David while
he is away I talked about on yesterday's
bonus show the fact that Adam Schiff was
censured by the Republican Party in the
House of Representatives for his role in
investigating Donald Trump yet another
as I mentioned yesterday distraction
attempt to take the attention away from
the chaos that is their own party and
the chaos that is Trump the leading uh
candidate right now within their parties
presidential primary
um and so instead it has to be something
like this and an attempt to show the
base once again we're still
Pro Trump well I want to look at some
remarks the atom shift delivered
um when he had a chance to talk
responding to this effort and some
really good stuff before we do that
though this is from The New York Times
the GOP led a house formally censured
representative Adam B Schiff Democrat of
California on Wednesday over his role
investigating form president Donald J
Trump the first in what could be a
series of votes seeking to punish those
who Republicans have deemed the party's
enemies the center passed by a party
line vote of 213 to
209 with six Republicans voting present
the measures had the backing of speaker
Kevin McCarthy after its lead sponsor
representative Anna Paulina Luna
Republican of Florida altered this
language to remove a multi-million
dollar fine some Republicans viewed as
unconstitutional
so with that being said uh here's this
from Adam Schiff
to my Republican colleagues who
introduced this resolution I thank you
you honor me with your enmity you
flatter me with this falsehood you who
are the authors of a big lie about the
last election must condemn the truth
tellers and I stand proudly before you
your words tell me that I have been
effective in the defense of our
democracy and I am grateful
and yet this false and defamatory
resolution comes at a considerable cost
to the country and to the Congress at a
moment when millions of people in our
home state of California are unable to
find a place to live or afford a place
to live speaker McCarthy chooses to
occupy the resources of Congress for two
straight weeks on this hollow sop to the
Maga crowd he offers nothing to those
who are homeless or addicted to opioids
or to millions of college students mired
in debt but this paltry distraction
Donald Trump is under indictment for
actions that jeopardize our national
security and McCarthy would spend the
nation's time on Petty political payback
thinking he can censure or find Trump's
opposition into submission
we'll stop that one there and before
discussing further I'll show you one
more from this bit of remarks
no matter how
locations or Slanders you level against
me you butt indict yourselves as Liz
Cheney said there will come a day when
Donald Trump is gone but your dishonor
will remain
this resolution attacks me for
initiating an investigation into Trump
campaign solicitation and acceptance of
Russian help in the 2016 election even
though the investigation was first led
not by me but by a republican chairman
it would hold that when you give
internal campaign polling data and
you're polling data to a Russian
intelligence operative while Russian
intelligence is helping your campaign as
Trump's campaign chairman did that you
must not call that collusion though that
is its and you've heard him make that
case before we'll stop that one
there so a couple things on this first
off the reference to Liz Cheney saying
they'll come a day when Donald Trump is
gone but your dishonor will remain that
is
just so applicable to the modern day
Republican party it is done so much to
destroy itself in its own integrity
for the purpose of supporting Trump
and right now that's helping a lot of
people be politically successful I guess
I mean also losing a lot but some
individuals get the support of the base
because they do that so it might seem
reasonable in their eyes but one day
Trump will be gone and only as was said
the dishonor
um the humiliation that was this part of
American History this part of the
Republican Party being the Maga GOP
that's what will be remembered and that
should horrify these individuals who are
going along with this movement the other
thing is Adam Schiff used the word
multiple times I think distraction and
something I talk a lot about on my own
show uh you can find that at Luke
Beasley on YouTube is distraction the
distraction politics that is played by
the Republican party and the reality
that because right now the modern uh
Republican party is putting forward
policies that just when they do put them
forward explicitly that just aren't
beneficial to the lives of their own
constituents in large part I mean what
is the big economic accomplishment for
the most part over the last multiple
decades from Republican administrations
and Congress is tax cuts right tax cuts
for the wealthy and so often their
governance just serves
to make the powerful more powerful and
the wealthy more wealthy and they aren't
more fiscally responsible while doing so
when you look at the record comparing
different parties in recent history and
they aren't better for the economy
looking at pretty much every metric we
use to measure the economy of the last
100 years or something and so with both
of those in mind and the fact that their
policies aren't directed most of the
time
um at benefiting the lives of the
working class why would people vote for
them why on Earth would people vote for
them well it's because they're effective
at branding one of the things I also say
a lot is the GOP is really effective at
one thing and that's branding and
they're really good at bumper sticker
politics making some message solidifying
down a message into something that
resonates with people but often doesn't
actually reflect an authentic policy
proposal that would benefit that
person's life
so with all that in mind the way that
they get people to continue supporting
them and thinking that they're fighting
in the interest of them when in reality
they're just assisting in making the
wealthy more wealthy the powerful more
powerful while demonizing tons of people
and all that is by doing the distraction
just by doing stuff like this so people
go yes they're standing up for Trump or
by dehumanizing and demonizing so many
populations of people or saying woke
woke woke way it's the biggest threat to
America woke woke woke
and on and on it goes if you're focused
on that you're less focused on their
lack of actual policy uh proposals that
would benefit your life
speak of the house Kevin McCarthy
responded to the hunter Biden
uh plea agreement and we talked about
this on yesterday's show Hunter Biden is
expected to plead guilty to two
misdemeanor charges in relation to not
paying his taxes
um he since has paid them back but not
paying them for a time there and then he
will get one felony gun related charge
dismissed he lied on a form saying he
wasn't addicted to a control substance
to get a gun when he was and that will
be dismissed if he follows through with
certain guidelines and the narrative
from the right as we talked about
yesterday has been sweetheart deal this
is a sweetheart deal and we're kind of
wrapping up the week so I'm going back
to some clips I didn't have a chance to
talk about this being one of them just
because of the dishonesty that is
gushing out of Kevin McCarthy it's
notable that this is how dishonest so
many people have to be to cover for
Trump and their narrative that uh
there's this two-tier justice system
hurting people like Trump so here's the
first clip
we'll look at it
the two-tier system in America if you
were the president's leading political
opponent the doj tries to literally put
you in jail give you prison if you are
the president's son you get a sweetheart
now this does nothing to our
investigation it actually should enhance
our investigation because the doj should
not be able to withhold any information
now saying that because a pending
investigation they should be able to
provide chairman Comer with any
information that he requires so you
heard him say
the fact that the doj would try to put
the political opponent of the president
in jail while giving a sweetheart deal
to Hunter Biden
um proves the two-tier justice system
talking point we've been perpetuating
which we'll talk about Trump but I'll
show this clip I think I showed this uh
one yesterday once again to remind you
that that talking point of sweetheart
deal is not accurate then we'll Circle
back to the Trump component obviously
you're already hearing a lot of shouting
oh sweetheart deal oh this oh that none
of us really knows the details of the
possible charges here and exactly what
was agreed to as part of this plea
Jennifer but how do how does one assess
whether this is the type of deal that a
normal person not a President's child
would get in this circumstance so you
would look to other similar cases right
so on the gun form charge it's very very
standard for someone in this situation
who lies on the form because they're an
addict the gun is long gone apparently
only had it for a couple of weeks it's
very standard in these circumstances for
this diversion to occur and to wipe out
the charges assuming he successfully
completes it so that's totally standard
and the tax fraud is is similar as well
I mean he paid those taxes back a long
time ago that's something that doj takes
very very seriously when okay and when
you look at historical precedent when
you look at other cases like this one
it's not some sweetheart deal
um but then he mentioned Trump and this
is a narrative then we have one more
clip to get two of Kevin McCarthy with
Monty Raju but it's a narrative that is
so present right now it's so annoying oh
the doj's trying to lock up the
political opponent of Biden
what that tries to do is to take the
conversation away from
what Trump is being accused of because
if there was nothing substantive to what
Trump was being accused of then you
could have a conversation about why are
these charges being brought then but the
indictment is extensive in the evidence
it brings forward so then what is so
enraging is that individuals like Kim
McCarthy refuse to just completely
engage with the evidence engage with the
accusations because if they were to do
that then the conversation is no longer
Hunter Biden got a sweetheart deal when
he didn't and Trump is getting locked up
which we'll see obviously the whole he
has his due process and everything but
if that ends up happening and Trump was
indicted see that shows inherently
there's something unfair they couldn't
do that because they would have to argue
then therefore
uh not enforcing the laws that Trump is
being accused of violating which they
would never say they would never
explicitly say no yeah I don't think we
should enforce the Espionage Act I don't
think we should enforce that
or I don't think we should protect
National Security Secrets they would
never want to say that so it just has to
be vaguely Trump's being indicted and
Hillary's not yeah well what are the
facts of the case
uh here's another moment
Congress has to have a right we have the
constitutional right to investigate and
to oversee and for any investigation
that we have or any information we need
they can't now stand behind that there's
an investigation going on but there's
two separate cases I mean the Trump
cases involving alleged obstruction of
an investigation alleged misstatements
this is a tax case and a gun case these
are two separate cases why conflate them
I'm not conflating them but they're
allegingly lied to investigators that's
that's the issue handle it different
well did did Hunter Biden lie about his
taxes that Hunter Biden lie about the
gun well I don't know he pleaded guilty
to the situation those get that
situations well there's no there's no
time for him to serve remember this will
be no prison time but they're trying to
put president Trump in prison that's
what they're different cases is there
different facts about equal Equal
justice
what
you talk about equal dresses is that
what you think Equal justice is Kevin
McCarthy okay the universe says if Trump
is indicted then that means some
democrat somewhere has to be indicted
what
oh it's so unserious it is so
humiliating why why is that the
narrative and people have said this uh I
went as you all know to Miami to Trump's
arrested arraignment and talk to Trump's
pores and one of them actually a bunch
of them but one of them kept repeating
well why hasn't Hillary been indicted
that's not how it works because Hillary
didn't do the things or there wasn't
evidence for her doing the things that
Trump did
they didn't uncover the very Criminal
Intent that it seems they're uncovering
uncovering with Trump and they didn't
even ever get accused of the same things
why are so that's one level of absurdity
the Hillary or Biden conflation with
with Trump
a whole nother level of uh conflation is
saying that Hunter Biden should be
compared with Trump's case
hunterbind was accused of evading his
taxes for two years and lying on a
Federal Form about a gun
Trump's accused of you know
keeping classified information he's not
supposed to have lying to Federal
authorities about having the classified
information
obstructing an investigation as they're
trying to get back the classified
information
um and on and on conspiring with other
individuals to keep out of the hands of
federal authorities these classified
documents and that compares to Hunter
Biden Howe that's as absurd as
um
you're accused for any crime and you
start talking about someone's speeding
ticket that that should Justice should
be served there too but just very
different levels of Justice unless
they're saying that all the other cases
that have ended in very similar deals as
the hunter Biden one has should have led
to prison sentences which I don't think
they would say can you imagine if Trump
did the very things
um can you imagine if Trump went to
prison for evading his taxes
they would go
bonkers
I don't even know how that would work
but
um or he lied on a federal Forum about
getting a firearm and they put him in
prison
they would go Bonkers
um but dishonesty is inevitably going to
lead to a humiliating moment like that
one I guess we have much more on the
other side of this break
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show
during a recent interview with Sebastian
Gorka Donald Trump continued to promise
what he has been quite frequently
recently which is they're going to
indict me well I'm going to indict them
then
um
and I'll show you this moment and then
we'll discuss really dangerous rhetoric
and numbers are through the roof we're
beating everybody by a lot and we're
beating Biden by a lot and one of the
reasons it was interesting somebody
wrote a very strong piece the other day
I could tell you who but let's not even
use this name because perhaps you
wouldn't want it but wrote a very strong
piece that they're afraid to have me
back in that's why they're doing the
indictment stuff because they don't want
to be indicted now I would do it only
very fairly of course of course but they
don't want to be indicted so they say we
can't let this guy win but there was
tremendous corruption on the other side
don't forget they spied on my campaign
and we caught them
they did things that nobody would have
believed then they had two fake
impeachments that we won and so much
else the Mueller report which showed new
collusion at the end of two years showed
no collusion and number
okay so uh we also heard a similar
sentiment during his recent Bedminster
speech in addition to the
criminal elements that have illegally
invaded our country
make it America energy independent and
even dominant again and immediately
ending the war between Russia and
Ukraine I'll have it ended in 24 hours
[Music]
I will appoint a real special prosecutor
to go after the most corrupt president
in the history of the United States of
America Joe Biden
and the entire Biden crime family
so what's fascinating is we've heard
from
uh
Republicans for a while now we've talked
about this a lot this week and even just
on the show that there's this two-tier
justice system designed to go after
conservatives and benefit Democrats and
that's what Trump is a victim of and the
evidence they bring forward is not
evidence they don't break forward
evidence I guess it's just the
accusation very empty and that is going
to then be the justification to actually
weaponize the government against people
based on their political
affiliation and if Trump were to become
president he actually is committing to
weaponizing his office to go after his
political opponents to go after the
Biden crime family it's not let the
system play out
if there's crimes investigate them if
there's something
that is a clear violence violation of
Law and has evidence for that that can
be proven in court law all that let the
process play itself out as president I
want to be separated from that no it's
going to be I'm going to figure out a
way to get Biden locked up and it's a
similar thing we're seeing with this
weaponization subcommittee within the
House of Representatives where it's by
its name supposed to be looking into the
weaponization of the federal government
um but in reality it's those individuals
in their positions in the federal
government weaponizing that position in
the federal government to help Trump
politically and to
um perpetuate these conspiracy theories
about the FBI doing this thing and that
thing and Twitter and uh Jim Jordan
trying to get involved in the Manhattan
D.A investigation in
the name of investigating the
weaponization of the federal government
they're weaponizing the federal
government and
um it's pretty terrifying thinking about
the prospect of trump using his position
if God forbid he were able to get back
into that position in that way one other
narrative that kind of was intertwined
in that little clip you saw was one he
also recently posted about on true
social here's a screenshot it says
Congress will hopefully now look at the
ever continuing witch hunts in election
interference against me on perfectly
legal boxes of course that doesn't seem
to be accurate and what I've been
warning of and talking about a good bit
on my show you can find that at Luke
Beasley on YouTube definitely go check
out my show if you uh are liking what
you're watching now
is that Trump is preparing similar to
how he did before 2020 to claim on
election interference that was fraud but
this time while he'll probably include
dead voters and we talked about earlier
in today's show Ruby Friedman or Freeman
and claims like that the suitcases and
ballot stuffing a big massive dump some
ballot dumps all over the place he will
probably make those claims as well and
on top of it he'll say it was rigged if
he loses to Joe Biden because of
election interference when in reality
what we're seeing is just Trump being
held accountable for his violations of
the law it has been great being with you
today
um one more reminder to check me out at
Luke Beasley on YouTube make sure you
are also subscribed to this YouTube
channel the David Pacman show and I will
see you if you remember on the bonus
show
thanks a lot for watching Today's Show I
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors for all of the
books I don't have time for I use short
form which condenses thousands of
non-fiction books down into an excellent
summary that I can read or listen to all
at once short form goes chapter by
chapter providing deeper analysis than
other summary platforms for a more
comprehensive understanding of any topic
try it free and get 25 off using my link
below